this is cruz
he's a malayan taper
and he is hungry
malay and tapas are the largest of the
four species of taper and are the only
one native to asia
a close relative of the horse and
rhinoceros tapers have poor eyesight but
their sense of hearing and smell are
finely tuned
if threatened or frightened they've been
known to demonstrate pretty quick bursts
of speed
they are also excellent swimmers and
will seek refuge from predators in deep
water while using their flexible nose as
a snorkel
although they are vegetarians they can
also defend themselves with a bite from
their razor-sharp teeth
their distinctive black and white coat
looks very smart and also serves as an
excellent camouflage
predators will often mistake a taper for
a large rock when they lie down to sleep
despite these adaptations tapers are
extremely threatened
deforestation and encroaching human
development like flooding from
hydroelectric projects are all threats
to their shrinking habitat
this is the malayan taper